unless you're not trying to make
any profit from a movie you really have
to understand genre
do you decide on the genre before you
come up with a movie idea i do now but i
didn't used to do that
and and the reason why i do that now is
um after las vegas story
part of the reason why i didn't get a
distribution deal was because
it was a drama and it was really hard
when you don't have like a star in in
that movie
um and that
kind of failure made me quite or you
know reassess like okay what does this
all mean and i talked to a lot of
distributors and i started understanding
more of the business side of things
and and now when i make a film i'm very
conscious of like what genre and
what the audience is for this movie
and um yeah because you know if you're
trying to make a living
in the movie business like you really
have to kind of have that in focus
whereas before i was really
you know much younger and it was really
just about making a movie and telling a
story
but within the commercial world you
really
unless you're not trying to make
any profit from a movie you really have
to understand genre and and what is the
requirement of every genre
what are your favorite movie genres um i
really like sci-fi movies
um
but i also really like dramas
so
but when i was really young i used to
love horror movies
now
um i still like horror but
only like
a smart horror you know like something
like get out was pretty cool for me
um
but yeah sci-fi definitely because i've
always liked to see
different worlds
that potentially could you know happen
in our world um so that's why sci-fi is
something that really draws me
with bang bang and then las vegas story
it seems like you're drawn to sort of
this crime underworld
that then you know maybe
um
there's there's a humanizing element to
it it's not all i mean i'm just
just from the trailers that i've watched
so
can you talk about that
yeah so the other genre that i really
like is
um crime drama or just dark dark things
i've always been drawn to the underbelly
of society
and
i don't know there's something
interesting about
or more interesting to me
about somebody who
is like
trying to get by scraping by and
you know the things that this person
would do
to like make some money um
and it's always
that world you never really see it that
much
because
i think i mean i think most people live
pretty okay life you know you're not
like dealing with drug dealers all the
time and
going into
you know crime bosses uh houses and
stuff
um and
and like you know the way they portrayed
in movies
i don't know if all that is true so
that's what makes me more interested in
that kind of world of like okay what is
that world really like
yeah and that's i think that's why in
some of my movies i really go into this
underbelly and and really kind of
explore the psyche of somebody who's you
know at the edge
and and um
with what they'll do to you know make a
buck
did anyone try to talk you out of it and
say hey byron can you just make why
don't you make like a love story that's
where two people are in college not
where
one is you know got an underground
gambling ring or something you know
um no nobody actually really tried to
talk me out of it i feel like i really
didn't have that many um mentors in the
film industry
so
you know even at my film school which i
wouldn't even call film school
[Music]
like
it was very theoretical like they just
made us watch a bunch of old european
movies and we wrote some papers about it
but there was never
yeah there was never really much
guidance in terms of okay
this is how you you know make a living
in the film business this is what you
have to do these are the types of you
know jobs you can get there was really
none of that
well i've heard that about other film
programs and that you know you're
learning film theory and
you know just certain criticism and and
uh maybe camera styles but but there's
maybe not always real world
um maybe that's changed i don't know i
haven't gone to film school so i don't
know how that is but that's something
i've heard about other film schools as
well but it sounds like you you like to
kind of be
the man on the street a little bit and
really be amongst the people and
and um yeah and kind of feel what it's
like to
you know if you've ever gone to the
metro station in la you know you can
feel
sort of the heartbeat of l.a
just being yeah
yeah i like to get out there and wander
around and talk to different characters
different people
i think ever since i was a kid
you know i was free to go out and
do whatever hang out with people
um so there was never like because i
know some people when they're growing up
they're sheltered or like their parents
are very strict like for me you know i
grew up with a single mom
she was
dealing with her own issues
so there was never you know
like i was free to go out at any time in
the day or night
um
and and i did that with my friends and a
lot of my friends were kind of in the
same situation you know we would just
like sneak out at night and go to
parties or hang out wherever
and i think that kind of
feeling of want to get out and explore
and meet different people
carried over you know even in my 20s
even in college and after
um there's always a part of me that want
to get out
and i think that might be reflected in
some of my movies and the themes of like
somebody feeling trapped trying to get
out
um i don't know exactly where that comes
from but you know probably do a
psychoanalysis
that's interesting because you said with
bang bang and forgive me i haven't seen
it but
that one is from sort of a
bourgeois world and one is from sort of
a working working-class
world and both are trying to get out
almost yeah yeah they're trying to cross
over into each other's worlds
right i mean each one has a trap you
know bourgeois you got to keep up
appearances and make sure everybody
thinks everything is good and then the
working class is
you know the monthly rent
food bills and and other things that
come with being poor and yep
why is genre so important to you
well now i understand why genre is so
important is because
if you don't have a
genre that you're fitting you're moving
into then you're not going to be able to
sell that movie
so
you have to understand the genre that
you're working in
if you want
i guess to appeal to
your audience
so with a las vegas story there wasn't
enough of a genre or you said that
distributors didn't want it because they
felt there wasn't a quote unquote star
yeah so with las vegas story ultimately
it's a drama it's a family drama
although you know maybe from the trailer
or whatnot you might think okay there's
like some crime elements or it's like a
thriller but if you actually watch the
movie it's really a family drama it's
about this woman and her family
and she's
you know just trying to get by trying to
support
her family
and there's some friends that come into
her life but really it's just a drama
and what the distributors told me was
hey dramas are really hard to sell
unless you have
a star in there
and and although i had eric roberts he
wasn't really a bankable star
and that has to do with you know he's in
a bunch of like
indie movies he does tons of movies like
year-round he's constantly working
so what happens is you know as a
distributor you have
you know so and so movies coming to you
and like five of them have eric roberts
why would you take a sixth movie that
has eric roberts and nobody else
right like you can have him but some
other stars in there too but if you just
have him they're like yeah we have five
movies with him already in it like what
else why would i take your movie
interesting i mean i enjoy watching
aircraft i loved him in star 80 i don't
know did you see that the dorothy
stratton story no no okay yeah that's
going a few years back but you know he
i think he would be enough of a draw for
me to see it but yeah i understand i
guess maybe if there's
so much content out there with one
person yeah
which genre have you had the most
success with
success i don't know if i really have
found much success with any of the
movies
um i would say
i mean honestly i feel like my first
movie
probably
i mean it definitely made the most money
um so gangster drama would definitely be
it
um and and i think a big part of that
was
there was really no movie like that i
mean there were a couple of things out
there but
i think my movie was one of the newer
ones at that point to really portray the
asian gang lifestyle in a realistic way
and
and i had this lead actor who his name
is ty vietg
and he was like a rapper from the 90s
he was like the first rapper who went
viral before
youtube or anything like people were
passing his um mp3 around on like
you know discs
on dvds or whatever
um so he had a fan base already and
that's what kind of drew him in uh drew
his fans into the movie
and then
yeah i think i really hit like a niche
audience with that because a lot of
people i mean there were people buying
them dvd from australia or ireland
like of all like
you know holland
all sorts of places from all around the
world and they were just like
they're all you know vietnamese or asian
young kids who are like oh i have to get
this movie because like this is my life
or you know i've never seen anything
like this
yeah or or the the wealthy kids that
sort of wanna they feel at home in that
family even though maybe that's yeah not
what they actually yeah there was a few
kids where they're like that kid charlie
that that's like me when i was in high
school
so there was a lot of people that
related to it you know
and how did you meet the rapper
i just found him online um i had known
about him you know i at least listen to
his music in high school
and um i just reached out to him through
an email that i found
and where did he grow up
he's originally from portland oregon oh
wow okay interesting
and so then you you made him an offer
and he
yeah um i told him about the movie idea
i sent him the script and then he came
out to san diego and we you know had
lunch and i told him like what i want to
do
and he was like all right yeah he was
down to do it you know
do you think he was a huge draw for the
film
oh yeah definitely i think that was you
know
everybody who grew up during the 90s
like knew about him and so for for them
to see him in the first movie role
um like i would have paid to watch that
movie and that's kind of how i
approached the movie you know i was like
what would i want to watch
um and yeah that's kind of how i did it
why not stick with one
genre and just build your career with
that
be known as
the guy that does
blank he just keeps making great films
in that one genre
i mean some people can do it and if they
can do it they should do it um that's
what i've heard from people that you
just stick to your lane and you know
be known as the guy who does
the horror movies
in whatever way right
but for me personally like it's hard for
me to
kind of
put myself in a box like that
because
like when i think of an idea and i get
stuck on an idea
like that idea will lend itself into
what genre is supposed to be right
um
and also sometimes i
like if i've already written um a horror
movie like it's hard for me to write
another horror movie
because i might be inspired to write
another kind of movie
um but that's just me like i've tried to
do that where i'm like okay i'm gonna
write horror movies only because you
know that's what sells
so i did i wrote like two horror movies
and after that somehow i started writing
a science fiction movie
so
yeah it's hard for me to stick to one
genre
so just like you said earlier you like
to kind of wander
and be free it sounds like in your
creativity it's the same way yeah yeah
it's a great way to put it okay so you
don't want to be you know boxed in by
yeah
you could do a movie about a filmmaker
who's trapped in one genre
and they can't get out and they
how much do you think it hurts a
filmmaker to not stay in one genre
to not stay in one genre i don't
so i know i've heard this from you know
professionals and and whoever
but i don't know if that's really true
and it's definitely not true for um for
everyone because i know of a writer
a friend of mine who
you know she wrote
a horror script
and then she wrote a comedy
and
she got staffed on the show because
that show was
a horror but with a little bit of a
comedic kind of thing in it so when she
showed them both of those scripts she
got staffed
now a lot of you know
writing coaches or whoever will tell you
oh just stick to your genre right you
know
like first write one thing and then when
you get big you can like branch off
but you know for this girl that wasn't
the case and if she didn't have that
comedy script ready to go
then she wouldn't have gotten that job
you